all right um wonderful to uh have
everyone here uh in this in this
tutorial this is the first talk of the
day I'm based in um Ireland but today
I'm in India I'm in my holidays and
today I will I will be talking about how
to build contextual chatbot using llm
Vector databases and most importantly
python uh I'm a I'm a senior data
scientist and a manager in ey Ireland
and in my part-time I love to do some
Community work including uh being the
education lead at women Inland which is
a a nonprofit do tank organization where
we encourage more women to join the AI
space and not just in like technical
capacity but also at executive levels
for beginners um and practitioners
alike now coming starting with the um
with this massive blowout that we got
got after the introduction of chart gbd
the world changed after 30th of November
2022 when chart gbd was released we got
a lot of news ranging from you know
having how accurate the responses are um
how it's going to you know snatch all
our jobs uh is is that is is that the
aim for Google search engines um but but
in the process we what we figured out is
that having GPT your the llms is is a
boon for our industry we figured out in
the last one year not just you know um
how we can generate accurate answers but
also how to use it to benefit our our
businesses how well we can leverage it
not just you know for generating answers
but also like for multiple other tasks
uh behind the scenes um for for example
for for Expediting classification
annotation text annotations tasks for
very large text text based data that
used to be very very complicated today
they have all become much more easier
and that's all because of of of the of
the starting of chat GPT uh I think uh
the end of last year okay so what is
what is that the Crux of of chat GPT um
or what is this entire thing about it's
it's all about generative AI we are we
are able to generate content that we've
not seen before or the structure of it
that we hav't seen before but it's based
very much on the training data that it's
seen and been trained on um uh
um um the the whole AI ecosystem where
does generative AI lie so we'll start
with AI what is ai ai is is is an e
ecosystem of algorithms or machines that
understands and has the ability to um
you know predict uh something the future
A system that has the ability to learn
from you know past data points and then
you know uh predict something uh um
further a subset of AI is machine
learning where machines learn based on
the provided data and deep learning it
does the same thing but using um
artificial neural networks uh but has
the ability to learn more complex
patterns within the data itself and
where does generative AI fit in here so
there are different kinds of tasks that
AI or um machine learning strives to
accomplish including um including uh you
know discriminative tasks and um
generative tasks the discriminative
tasks are more around you know
classification or identification
predictions and generative tasks are
more about generating content or
generating texts and images and that is
where generative AI comes in and it is
based on neural networks in the in in
the heart of it um and where does llm
sit in this in this whole ecosystem it
it is a conjunction between uh machine
learning deep learning and generative AI
because these are models that serve
generative AI but they are also umns and
you know traditional machine learning um
Concepts as well beneath it so basically
in the heart of gvi there's there's
behind the scenes it's it's a large
transform it's a large large Transformer
model that has all the worldly knowledge
up till the date it has been trained on
that comes with that disclaimer always
but it has massive massive knowledge
that has from you know uh whatever it
has publicly um available on the
internet and it always comes with some
sort of um um drawbacks as well but
we'll see about it later now that we're
talking about large language models and
how if we've grown from you know models
that would be only in a in a range of
like features of only of thousands to
having like trillions of features in um
in them and which is which is given us
really really high accuracy but then how
how does it how how does it compare to
the existing ones so what we have today
is GPT 4 which is the latest one gp4 um
turbo to be specific the the latest one
to be
released and um so and it has got about
1.7 trillion par parameters which is a
thousand times in that of um the gbd3 uh
which has already been like really that
the efficiency of GB3 was good gbd gbd4
is even better um but the question is
how far how far do you think how how can
we um H how much can we scale our
parameters our features so much um
efficiency is going to increase right
but um can can can uh how how how are we
going to manage the infrastructural
costs in in that sense so because
holding that large feature set is is
very difficult but yes so large language
models they they range up to like
billions and trillions of features as
you can see on the screen and um gp3 has
about 1 billion and the GP uh and gbd4
has about 1.7 trillion
parameters okay
so behind the scenes how it works so
like I say that it's a very large
Transformer Transformer model uh there's
there there was a research paper that
came out um a while back which was um
which was about um how we can use
attension self attention which is
technique to use uh to build these
Transformer models um it basically a
transfer model basically has two
components um basic components one is
the encoding component the other one is
the decoding component the encoding
component encodes incoming text in
certain format and the decoding
component has the um is tasked to to
understand patterns and um decode that
encoded component and learn from the
patterns while decoding it and
especially by you know predicting blank
blank um blank text within the within
the incoming texts and that's how that's
how uh large language models work at a
very high level okay um and it does it
it accomplishes all of this by learning
from a very large amount of data that is
number one number two from billions and
billions of parameters that it uh learns
from these encoded components uh while
decoding it and this is an unsupervised
learning technique which is also massive
because um while we've got like a you
know vast in vast information in the
internet but um it's not possible for us
humans to just you know annotate U
annotate each and every one of them
because for supervised learning you need
to provide an an an explanation a label
for every single um article that you
feed in or like for a spefic task
whatever for that kind of vast um vast
um information it's literally impossible
for um us to provide um metadata along
with it so therefore unsup supervised
learning in large language models and
transform models have been really really
helpful for us to derive um benefit from
information without being without it
being a very laborious
task um in terms of applications of llms
um the first thing that comes to your
mind when you see chat GPT your your
ability to you know interact with uh the
questions and answers uh your ability to
ask cross questions on top of the
questions you've already asked you know
um that has opened up doors into
Marketing sales and support that's that
was the main focus when it first started
started when I attended some talks
people were talking about you know uh
how how it can enhance customer support
and I think that that that's the first
you know sector in the industry that has
um embraced or started experimenting
with um generative AI or llms just to
begin with um how it can do it it can it
can scan records it can you know uh
generate insights it can it can send
like human-like responses which was
which was missing from rule based
rule-based um engines
initially um it can also what it can
also do is it can do some general
writing or note taking note taking must
have seen the applications nowadays in
um in Zoom um I've seen like some of my
teammates in women in AI they they they
take automatic nodes when they're absent
from the calls and for General writing
um we've seen use cases where uh We've
generated job descriptions for a
recruitment teams and um for um for
social media content as well um which
is which is which has been really
beneficial to you know draft like that
first draft um using really fancy words
and given if you give proper
instructions like what smilees to add if
if you at if you at all want smilees if
you want it in bullet format if you want
it you know in you know three sentence
or if you want long text whatever
instruction you pass into the llm it it
responds in a in a in a detailed fashion
and then and the next one very important
code and we've been seeing uh we've been
you know massively using um uh code
co-pilot uh Microsoft's co-pilot as well
and um I tested it it's very efficient
and um I personally worked on some um
you know code generation techniques it
was wasn't it was very crude it was just
it was before the llms came in uh
generative I came in and uh I can tell
you I can promise you it was a really
really difficult task but since M came
in and then I started looking at these
co-pilots and I was like okay I could do
a lot more with this and um it's it's
actually very um good for learning
coding as well um and writing very
efficient code improving your code
quality um and then you know migrations
as well like if you use it well you
should be able to um leverage llms for
you know removing a lot of the mundane
part of your software engineering
routine and
in terms of the others um you know image
and speech gener uh image and you know
speech synthesis and then video
Generations well you can use them for
your for for your good but then you know
you have to be aware of the
the the not so good applications of llms
which which is rampant nowadays I think
um I I've seen a lot of you know spams
have increased a lot of um um a lot of
spams have increased nowaday um but then
yeah so these are these are you know
roughly the applications of llms and
today what we our agenda is to look at
how how do we design a chatbot um that
understands context and then can respond
back to you um um that can respond
respond back to you in natural language
it refers to an an information of you
know pool of PDF data that you pass it
in and then it should be able to answer
you by reading through the document and
uh
present uh that information in a in a
more like natural language
manner okay so then now we writing the
open AI wave uh we have so you know when
it came in we kind of you know when we
started looking at um what it can do
like we didn't know when it
started what what are different
questions that you can ask so yeah we
can definitely I've asked question like
any generate job description like
template for a data scientist role or
like asking factual questions as on who
won the football World Cup in 2000 or
like you know asking for some kind of
advice medical advice or like whatever
and then and then very importantly as
you know software developers or like I'm
not a software developer I'm data
scientist so you know even like for
writing scripting code I can you know I
was testing with some different kinds of
um code that it can generate like um
well I I asked um it to generate some
code for heat map using Seaborn it um
well it did not it did not do very well
but then you know it did try to do a lot
of things that I think traditionally all
the large language models could have
done and then you know summarization
tasks and then you know everything on
like you know all the wh questions uh
what is when was how to where is and uh
you know generate some kind of a
template or generating stories you know
we were we were testing chat gbd almost
every single day but what has what
enabled that that huge wave like I would
rather call it a tsunami because it was
it was it was it was overwhelming and
the first and foremost reason for it
being so so popular is number one um
people who are not from software
computer science background um people in
business and you know Commerce they
wouldn't interact with AI at all um
because they you know AI would be
something very exotic that would you
know very very brainy people could only
interact with but what chat GPT or open
eii did is that gave it an interface and
opened it up for people to start using
of course to their own benefit because
they were using the feedback that they
were that they were getting from these
people who were testing it
but the ability to interact with an EI
agent in normal language was a massive
plus factor for why chart gbd or you
know chart gbd particularly became so um
popular and then The Uncanny ability to
answer all the questions you
ask yes the hallucinations were were you
know tough to um ask you could trick it
into answering questions and everything
but um you know I ask questions like you
know something about space like sun and
moon that would be really you know
difficult for it to answer but it was
like answering everything correctly and
I was I was really shocked when I um
when I was testing it for the first few
days and also it's terrific problem
solving skills it's not just doesn't
answer factual questions like you know
where you know from which side does the
sun rise it was actually ask um
answering mathematical questions as well
and drawing inferences
and reasoning reasoning based tasks
which was also very very impressive also
after once I learned you know prompt
engineering it also you know um I was
getting surprised even more like with
proper guidance or proper prompt
engineering how well you can get the
desired output or or make it do the the
thing that you want the llm to do so
that's why that's why there was this
huge wave of opening EI and here's and
here's one thing that came out of it is
prompt engineering prompt engineering
ruled 2020 three
um and here's here's a little you know
example of how it happen so the first
the first um example that was there in
the previous screen was G to job
description for data scientist role and
here in this example I have fleshed it
out a little bit more and gave it some
context um gave clear specification and
what exactly do you need in that in that
job description template what format do
you need so in the format I say can you
add a job summary key responsibilities
and benefits so basically clearly
defining what is the output structure to
it so these are the couple of you know
principles of writing a good prompt to
give proper context to give clear
specifications and to have a clear
format in output input and output
structure so that you know it can get it
can get the information and can
structure it and give it out to you in a
more you know digestible Manner and
that's what is what prompt engineering
is all about um and then and and not
just that it's also an interative
process so when you see the output for
that you would see like you probably
will have some some stuff in bullet
points you won't have everything in
bullets you might have like a a full
paragraph of you know what skill sets
are required but if you want the
response and bullet points you can
actually mention that again and in in
the next prompt and say like you know
can can you put it in bullet points
number one you can you can put it in get
give me a Chon output as well all these
kind of things you can you know you have
to build it iteratively so if you you
know at first go it's very difficult to
get everything right it's a very
iterative and you
know a process that requires a lot of
patience um to to to construct you know
something that you know gives exactly
what you need for
um and yeah so with that we'll go into a
little bit of Hands-On basic prompting
demo
um I will post the GitHub repository
link here
now
so in so if you want to follow along um
that's the the I will be uh using open
AI basic prompting um uh The Notebook
which which contains a basic template or
how you should be doing it
in in Python in your
notebook okay so when you start doing
it first you will need to in install
open aai and you need to register for
your openai
key all right you need to open
your um openi account get your API key
set it up uh you can directly use it
here you can directly use it put your
API key here but since I usually uh use
um the open key and then I will be
presenting not allowed to share my API
key I keep that in my environment
variables and this is how I fetch it os.
Environ and then I have this um the key
whose value is the API key um in
this in this a in this the first
important code is here which is
basically your backend code for your
chat gbd interface
[Music]
um so once so when I so first I in
instantiate open AI okay I need
initiated with my open AI um uh my API
key and then look at
this I have tried to use the chart
completions module from open AI that
uses that that allows you to use models
GPD 3.5 turbo and
gbd4 um as well in the chat completions
one because this is G these uh School of
gpts are suited for question answering
sort of um task
um not just like uncontrolled generation
this Bas this is specifically trained to
answer questions or per perform tasks
and it's it is designed to take in
instructions and perform accordingly
okay
so what you see here is first so that's
that's the module that I call in and
these are the arguments that I sent in
uh the parameters that we have here is
one the mo the model itself so you have
the ability to select which model that
which model um you want to use 3.5 turbo
you want to use um you know there are
other model models as well apart from
gpts um no I think there's only gpts for
chat completions for temperature
temperature is another important um
important um parameter which allows you
to tell the model tell the model how
creative you want to go if if it's zero
that means you want it to be very
factual you need you have a context
stick to the context that's what you're
saying to the model and then if you go
up to one or more than one so the range
is zero to two more than one it's more
gibberish and if if you go close to one
it's more it has the ability to go like
Go creative generate whatever it is 0.5
balances out creativity
factual and every single time you get a
different set of responses whereas with
temperature zero the variations are
relatively low because it's more factual
and it breaks the the the most likely um
most likely next words or most likely
words that could you know that fits your
answer okay that's temperature that's a
role of temperature messages is where
you set the context you that's where you
do your prompt engineering more it
contains um a role uh and it contains a
Content so the role say says who is the
speaking to the model system is the
model's environment itself when you say
RO system and then you put in a content
for it you're basically setting the
environment or the context like I have
said I've told chat GPT that you're a
recruitment assistant who helps in
writing job descriptions for advertising
amazing opportunities within XYZ and
bring you know write the right talent in
that's where I'm saying who is this
agent that's the role for system and
then role user is us who is asking the
questions who's trying to get something
out of you know this llms in the back
end and that content is basically the
prompt or the question that I'm asking
okay when we get the response that is
basically the um the a the AI the agent
me message that tells that gives you the
output the response and that's the
response that I had received and it says
sure here's
sure um sure here's a job description
for data scientist position and says
this is the title location insert
locations this is a template so it just
gives you
spaces
um uh sorry I can hear some Eco from the
audience if you want to mute yourself
that would be great
um okay and then you got company XY Z
and it picks up directly from this
information here within XYZ and also
ignores this little spelling mistake
there I did not notice and then it's got
responsibilities and requirements prefit
qualifications as well I did not uh you
know have any specific instructions to
fill this up but then but then this is
your first draft you can definitely you
know go back and say can you put in you
know XY Z in your preferred
qualifications as well and then says to
apply please submit your resume blah
blah blah now what else what else do I
want it um I said that okay so this rule
is for Dublin Ireland and can you tailor
it for an Irish audience and it what it
does it it just it adjusts the location
says the location is for Dublin Ireland
and says that you know the s data
scientists join our team in Dublin blah
so so what what it what I've done here
is number one I've given a clear
instruction as in what I want I have
said in what format I want I I added a
few Clauses that you know needs to take
care of I added a Content
system uh somebody's just asking if they
can take like a quick one minute to set
things up I don't know if you want oh
sure um do you wanna do you want any
help
um well um I can give you two minutes um
we have a lot more content to follow um
what you can do
is where can you tell me where you are
at
yeah the repo is quite
straightforward I think it's just uh
yeah probably just uh getting everything
installed and set up
but hopefully I'll caught hopefully all
caught up now on setting up their API
okay
great so when you when you use this
notebook you can directly put your API
key in here instead of this so like
that
okay so that would save you some time
from uh in uh putting in your API key in
your environment variables you can do
that
later uh but yeah the code is pretty
straightforward you will you can also
like not set a system uh system message
at all you can just go for your users
role uh users role and then just start
giving instructions so what it does it
detects if the role is Sy them then it
understand it's it's an environment
setting the environment setting the
context for the conversation to start
and then for role user um it'll start
you know sending back some responses uh
to your queries you can also pass in
more messages append more messages from
the system uh from the from the AI as
well your conversation between the role
user and the role system uh role um AI
agent and you can you know pass in
content context along with your um along
with your prompts in that scenario but
this is a very very simple
example and while you're at eight I'll
go back to
my um PowerPoint presentation
now
okay so now that you're aware of the
things that we need to use one is the
roles in open AI chat completion module
one is the sister system the user and
the assistant the system like I said
sets the context of the environment who
is the bot what are the general rules so
if there is anything that the that the
bot needs to take care of um as in you
know don't answer if somebody asks
something out of context so if this is a
if this is a recruitment assistant if
somebody asks about auditing like no I'm
not answering that question so you have
to set that rule in the system or the
environment for the user is so it's like
us ask a question riddle whatever you
need to give clear instructions like I
I've said before and a clear like output
format if you give very clean structured
input it can give you you know better
answers um because then it understands
it much better and then the assistant is
the response that you get from the
llm these are the three roles um that
you'll find in the module and then the
models so what we are looking at today
is the chart completion one that's the
second one in this um in this column the
first one is the language one where a
text goes in and text goes uh comes out
that was that was how it was and when
the GPT one 2 Neo um these came out gpt3
came out you know it's just text goes in
text comes out I've experimented with
loads of them you know it's it's great
for like open-ended generation which
does not have does not have to you know
take in more instructions from you know
from The Prompt but when it comes to
chat the second one it takes instruction
Specific Instructions that that you have
in the prompt and then it responds
therefore it's more more controlled has
some dependency on you know what you're
asking
for um and then the embeddings
embeddings is the codes or the vector
representation of these input texts the
way these Transformers so we have
already talked about this large uh
Transformer model that GRS in the back
end and we've talked about the encoder
and the decoder in the back end as well
that encoder when it you know when when
it decodes the the representation of
those inputs it sets into a very large
in this case in jup you know Force case
1.75 trillion so it just you know
creates all those numeric
representations for what corre character
so that it can process the information
in the back end so that's so these
embedding these embeddings are also
accessible to us um from these from open
Ai and from you know hugging pH as well
so hugging pH is another pository of all
the different you know um other other
other generative models llms as well
which it it has all different kinds of
um different different kinds of models
of language models chart completions or
you know even just generating
embeddings it can it has a repository of
all that but you know today we will
concentrate on open
AI um so yeah language chat and
embeddings for three types of it
and so now that we've seen like it has
got so much great stuff that you can
accomplish from llms um I hope everybody
is set up all you need to do is go to
open AI create your own uh account car
your opening I key um and set it up
exactly where I have um your underscore
opencore API uh uncomment that line put
your API key comment the next line where
I have set my um OS environment key and
you know just run you'll be able to
access the the the model
model um okay so now that we have
already discussed about what the great
things that llms can you know um
accomplish what it can also do is it can
present and correct or false information
that you're you're already aware of that
hallucinations uh can give generic
information whereas when a person asks
for specific response wouldn't get that
um information can be outdated um could
be inaccurate due to you know wrong
contextual references might not there
there is Lads of ambiguity but from a
traditional NLP standpoint ambiguousness
is one of the biggest challenges in you
know tech text processing tasks we have
we have a massive Improvement while by
using llms for for removing ambiguity
but then ambiguity comes in even more
advanced form so if LMS get confused
about the
context it can bring you inaccurate
information and therefore you have to be
very careful as in whatever llm says you
might that might not be exactly true so
you can see there's an example there who
won the 2024 presidential election says
my knowledge was last updated in
20121 um and and you should be you know
um unable to provide information about
events talk it after the date um so you
have to look up to the new source but
just doesn't say that you know 2020 we
are yet to go into 2024 it's not
possible so it still gives you the
possibility of getting the answer okay
but then you know that's um uh that's
something that we can handle ourselves
internally when when when we design
systems based on llms um it can also be
biased or non-c compliant with laws or
regulations there have been loads of um
there have been loads of um conjectures
about you know being you know it being
biased and non
compliant um and then not fing following
you know correct AI governance processes
what it does is it it hampers for for
people for intelligent people it's easy
to locate for people who believe it all
uh it'll be difficult for them to locate
exactly where um llms have gone wrong so
it only generates it generates based on
probab abilities it doesn't know it
doesn't understand it doesn't process
anything like humans
do um
so that's first and the second thing is
token limitation that has been very
difficult for us to solve because when I
started with I was like okay I fed in
some good bit of information and asked a
few questions it's like oh my God it can
just do all the comprehensions really
quickly but then comes the challenge of
feeding like a big PDF like 50 pages PDF
and asking questions about it like how
do I do and it has only a you know few
bits of token limitations and we got and
and there were loads of conversations
around how we could you know tackle this
challenge um there's there are methods
in which we can you know summarize the
pages and then summarize the next page
and then you know compress that
information into smaller chunks and then
feed it into the context but then um you
know how many how many times would you
have to compress compress information to
pass to fit into the token limitations
so all these kind of things that that
also reigned 2023 this year um
conversations around um how to tackle
this you know context window limitation
and um lank chain came in as you know
one of the saviors in terms of tackling
that issue and today we will see how we
can do it okay
um okay so that comes with that we come
to L chain and
um and then so what what Lang chain does
is it gives us the ability to interact
with a multitude of documents it could
be it could range from videos to audios
you have you know YouTube API as well
that gives you access to YouTube's
transcripts I use it once to you know
get you know long transcript for some
kind of um llms application building and
then you can you have the ability to
read PDFs you have the ability to read
to get you know audio transcripts as
well so you can you basically have the
ability to access data in a format that
you can use for you know training your
models or giving context your models
what it also gives you is the ability of
storing that information because you
know imagine 100 100 Pages PDF that you
got you know extracted all the
embeddings you need somewhere to store
it cannot store everything in the memory
so it gives the ability to interact with
storage um databases like um like chroma
DB that's what we're going to see today
um there there's fice as well and and
then what it also does is that it gives
you the ability to interact with
different kinds of models not just open
AI we're not talking about open AI we
also talking about hugging faces and all
the other on premise models that you can
build it gives you the ability to
interact with them so it's it's build a
full ecosystem with which you can you
know build
applications powered by large language
models it gives you the ability to
extract transform them into Victors
store it and bring in context gives you
similarity wrestles as well under the
hood and gives it to the model and helps
the model to understand that data and
give back the user relevant information
or desired information it's a so the
things that you need here to download is
um to install a stick token P PDF um
Lang chain and chroma DB uh just put
that in the um in the
chat
and if and then we will go
into while you while you start doing
that
um we can go through this architecture
diagram to understand to process how it
happens what's the what's the flow of um
what's the flow of information there um
and how how do we you know utilize llm
from the chat
interface okay uh is there any question
I can take a few questions and I'll wait
for you to set
up
okay I don't see any questions
so I'll start explaining what we're
doing today so like I said the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
convert all our data into a format that
the models models the llms can use the
fundamental one fundamentals of machine
learning is converting everything that
you have in numeric format in digestible
iic format that you know any kind of
model um can read and understand because
there there's it's all you know a game
of numbers and under the hood so first
and foremost starting from the left hand
side we have this this part from data
that gets chunk ified into you know a
number of chunks then each of these
chunks get embedded and then they are
put into a vector database um that
stores all these um numbers okay that
Vector database for us today is going to
be chroma DB
and chroma DB and um you need to store
all of that we'll see how we do we
accomplish that in the code or why we
need to chunk is that we need if if if
it's a very very large data data set or
like PDF we need to put them into
smaller chunks so that you know you can
handle them well if you handle if you
generate these embeddings well or you
can them correctly it'll be easy for the
vector database or you know Lang chains
modules to retrieve it in in a better
fashion
okay then then there are designing
Concepts as well if you put in like
chunks these chunks can have overlap so
that it trains some some context from
the previous chunk and has some context
from the you know the the chunk that
comes after so that's these are all for
you know having more efficient retrieval
so it's all about answering the correct
question right and that's how the
designing patterns they they are they
get
established so you got you you have the
data you put them into different chunks
and then um and then you go into you
embed them store it in the vector
database now what happens from the chat
interface from the chat interface the
the incoming arrow is the question that
you have asked so the question gets
embedded as well because the model has
to understand the question as well so
you have to convert your question in
natural language into numbers and then
um use semantic search which is
basically
similarity um similarity technique for
understanding how similar Tech these
texts are so basically relating the the
what has been said in the question to
understand what kind of information is
in the in the vector DB um get the most
similar context and then fetch that from
that put that into the model as the
context in you know the the role user
context is going to have that just that
information that fetches from Vector DB
and also passes the question along along
with it as the
question and the llm then generates a
response that comes back to the Chart
interface as the response for the
question that you've asked so
so you need to be prepared so every time
you you know process any kind of PDF or
any kind of data you have to refresh
your vector DB today we'll be I've used
a um a random PDF um for uh for this
presentation that I have vectorized and
put into the database if I have to
change if I change that if if I change
that PDF or I add in more PDFs I'll have
to refresh that entire training or
creating Vector database code so that it
you know refreshes with the new
embeddings and then you can ask
questions um related to those PDF
information and then you get the you get
the context you feed the context along
with the question that you asked to the
model um and then you show it on the
chart in interface so what for for the
chat interface I've used streamlit today
you can also use gradio it's also been
very well you know very popular this
year for um the chart interfaces I find
stream l a bit more a bit better
and I've been developing on um streamlit
um for a while so I thought it's more
easy for me than learning
gradio um so yeah is there any questions
so far if not I'll go straight into the
next
um into the next notebook that tells you
how to
use Lang chain um to ask questions to
your LM and feed created Vector database
and refer to the vector database to get
the context and the answer to your
question retain uh information in the
memory so basically the your chat
history in the memory so that you can
you know ask um you know you can refer
to them while you converse with the
llm
okay
so that's the link
there
um there it
is
okay so we'll go to this um notebook
now
um it also it also it requires you to
install so uh the Lang insult
dependencies I
had so you need to install Tik token P
PDF along with Lang chain before Lang
chain I
guess
so the cost for running these uh
notebooks for the workshop it's going to
be very low if um if you set up your API
key it's just like um when I started it
was free I got like $20 credit and I
could not even spend like $2 out of it
because
I was I was testing but like I was
testing I was sending loads of queries
but then um did not even end up spending
like $2 out of the $20 credit so it's um
it's pretty cheap it would it would only
like be less it would be less than like
50 cents I
think
okay so uh we go to this notebook so
what I have here is first I set like so
the model here is um I've used text
embedding Ada uh 002 that's that's the
embedding model which generates um the
embeddings uh what we will do is we have
we have this um
folder data
folder
um I have I haven't provided any um any
PDF data in the repository at all so
what you can do is you can create a you
can create a
um a folder called create a
folder um called data and um add a You
Know sample PDF in
it
okay
whichever like whatever you
like so I've used Globe so Globe is one
of the Python libraries that helps you
uh navigate through your uh data folder
struct your folder structures right so I
have used Globe to say so this is this
is the PDF that I've uh I had downloaded
from the internet just for just to show
you how this works um this is the model
and this is the vector DB directory so I
just named it as Vector DB SL chroma so
inside this um inside this the vector
database is going to get created and all
the MS are going to get stored in there
um I just demote that you know this is
how you can access all your PDFs so that
star says you know this this this um
says that everything that you have got
inside your data folder get all the PDFs
all the star.pdf all the PDFs in the
data folder and then what I've done here
is I have used P PDF loader which comes
explic which comes out of the box from
um Lang chain to load the
PDFs
iteratively and uh and then use it for
splitting
okay
um and then I pen each them into the
this um docs list and then after that
what I've done is so like I said you
have to split the documents or put them
into you know smaller chunks because
you're dealing with really really long
pieces of text and you need to make them
smaller and also you know have you know
it design it intelligibly so that fits
your model context window but it also is
is able to relate to the information
that you have previously okay and um how
how they how do they work they split the
text into smaller chunks and then they
start combining and then you know after
that it's it it it sums all of these
chunks up into the larger chunk until uh
until a certain size which is 2500 here
in this case is attained and once you
reach that size that and um and it it
makes a chunk its own piece of text and
then starts creating a new chunk of the
next step on the for the next chunk with
some overlap with the previous one and
that overlap size is what we say set
here as
250 um to customize uh to customize the
text splitter you need to know how how
you want to split the text and what is
the chunk size that that you want and
what is the overlap size as well that
you need and in this case we've used
recursive character splitter so what it
does it instead of taking just just the
length to split it it tries to search
these these um characters in the text
and tries to retain like if there's a
paragraph retains the paragraph or it's
it's a sentence that retains the
sentence as it is so it doesn't break
from in between so it it it reserves the
context within it and it it tries it
goes on it tries recursively first tries
tries to find these to uh the ne double
next lines and then the next line and
then the blank space this kind of this
kind of um structured order until it
goes into the you know smallest chunk
size that is it satisfies that that
equation and then that's how the that's
how the chunk size is um
developed and then once it's done so
this this is where I've initiated it
with the with the numbers and then I've
gone into splitting the documents
again uh which is the natural following
step and then now that we've done on
that next step would be um generating
the embeddings for those chunks right
following the um previous
diagram so in the embeddings what I've
done is I've called open AI embeddings
from Lang chain and um and what it does
is it creates these um the embeddings so
I have I've set my open a key so you can
pass your open a key again directly here
and then i' I've already set the model
as GPD 3.5 said that and set that the
chunk size for processing this is 16
this is not a requirement for this one I
had developed this for azures deployment
initially so that this is um this is a
mandatory one for Assurance deployment
but you can ignore it for your um for
your uh
notebook okay so this what it does it it
initiates um and generates Bings and
um and then uh in this step in the next
in the next cell I store them into a
into the vector DB the one that we've
used this time and this one is chroma DB
and uh from this from this documents um
I've put in the um embeddings the splits
and also the directory in which um Lang
chain is supposed to store the the the
encoded versions of of of the PDF that
I've passed
in and like I said why we need
embeddings we need these embeddings so
you can say these you can say embeddings
are more like vector databases uh sorry
our um our embs are like word vectors
which are basically numeric
representations of text and which helps
us assess how close they are in context
to um the to other texts and that helps
us to you know retrieve context or
retrieve answers traditionally and even
here but it's just that LMS are even
more powerful and therefore they have
the ability to get even more accurate
results um and generate more you know
human-like
responses so once we've done that uh
We've created the data Spectre database
now from
um from from these uh from the embedding
setting that I've created and passing
the splits splits contains all the this
this the splitted document the PDFs and
also uh and it stores the vector the
vectorized format into this directory
and so now once we've created this you
should see in your uh you should see in
your um
side uh in your side
for uh in inside the f folder that
contains the vector
database it should be created now in
your folder file explorer folder
structure
okay and
then so once you've done that so in
order to you see this um the cell number
nine it's more it's for you know once
you have already
finished um finished creating the vector
database and you log off how do you
retrieve it again you just need to pass
in where the d uh the directory lies and
then the embedding function and then the
embedding uh you need to find send in
send in like what is the specification
for embeddings and then it retrieves or
you know sets your you it retrieves your
vector DB from your um from your
storage okay so that's how you should be
retrieving your vector
database we'll keep it um commented
because we don't need it now but if you
if you've already trained this data
datase and then you need to access the
database um in the future you can just
start from this
step so now chatting with open okay I
see a question there so I'm meting are
like word vectors but for full sentences
phrases
paragraphs no they're they're they they
are for the the tokens they're not for
full sentences if not for full sentence
or phrase or
paragraphs
okay so
um now chatting with open AI so now we
get into the the more interesting part
where we are we will be you know
starting to chat with the
data what um so what we have we are
doing here is um we have we instantiate
and say that okay we are using chy 3.5
turbo model to interact with uh the llm
and I set the temperature as zero so
this is
our this is our llms um
specification okay and then we set uh a
memory
to to to store all the information that
the that the that we are interacting
with already with the l llm so that's
how we've done it uh setting that
setting chat history as memory key and
say like return messages true so
therefore
it'll it'll return the messages um that
you have you know previously talked
through with your with your
llm
is there any question so
far I hope everybody is
following
so now that we have so now that we have
um uh created this llm we have
instantiated llm we have instantiated
the the memory retention
policy and we have our um we will be uh
designing our
retriever so here what we've done and so
Vector DB as you see here in langin why
is it so easy to use it's
because
um it's why is it so easy is because it
gives so it doesn't um you don't have to
really you know encode all your you know
s similarity similarity strategies what
you can do is you can just set um Vector
DB as Retriever and you know what the
the vector DB acts it's got these
underlying modules which does your
similarity search for you and by default
it does um a similar your um
basic similarity search you can use some
Advanced uh similarity searches as well
which you can set as you know search
type there
um right and then you can you know give
that strategy but all but that's all you
need to know and that's all you need to
do um in order to retrieve the context
from the vector database okay and that's
your
Retriever and
then you you you get the conversation
retrieval chain which which allows you
to interact with the with the vector
database
in in Vector database uh while you're
conversing okay so you're sending so
this is your llm specification that
you're saying sending saying that okay
I'll be using GPD
3.5 and then you'll be using um
retriever this retriever
setting which is your default Retriever
and this is your memory setting so it
it's going to return the messages that
you've been you know talking conversing
with
it and we run
it and okay and so once we've done that
it takes some time to build it and then
that's that's all you need to do that's
your that you've instantiated your
conversational retrieval chain that's
where you start asking your questions
about the document okay so I'm just
going to run
all the celles
above and you should be able to ask
questions about your document
now
and you notice how it can also you know
detect your
um spelling mistakes as
well okay for Chroma DB I think you will
also need to have a Microsoft's visual
C++
tools build tools if you've got any
problem in um downloading that let me
know
okay and while you're installing if you
could also do pip install streamlit that
would help you to run the run the other
python python files that I have in
there okay all right so what's the
structure here so initially we saw
there's the the output for the basic
prompting is different the output for
this conversation retrieval chain is
different we got this question you have
this chat history so since you returned
true for memory it gives you it returns
back you your chat history there you can
see what you had asked what was the
response and all of this is fed back
again to retain in context
okay and uh so says this is the answer
there what is this document about this
this document is about a course offered
by Trinity College Dublin um in the
faculty of Arts blah
blah so then you can ask what are the
career opportunities it basically refers
back to the PDFs gets the relevant
information and answers your
question um says graduates of this
course have a range of career
opportunities and that's how and then
there are um in high demand blah blah
blah um
tells you you know what other
opportunities you have in the industry
and also in the research field blah blah
blah and and then you can continue on
this conversation uh
further okay and this is this is
basically the backbone this is basically
the backbone of how your you know how
this is basically the backbone of how
your chatbot interacts all you do with
streamlet is you give it an interface
this is your you know backend this this
is your job done
you can definitely try looking
at yeah so it's the yeah it's it's it's
the backbone of your it's the backbone
of your chatboard and you've got this um
you plug it into your uh your streamlit
code after that and refer it back and
forth once you've trained your vector
database and uh that code lies in
thep files in the in the talk
resources so let me start
[Music]
sharing so you can see this so all so
these P files of got this create.
P this is here I've basically organize
the entire code into a command so I can
access this from command line with
passing the argument for setting up this
a chunk size chunk overlap and the
embedding chunk sides if it's required
you can also extend this into uh you
know choosing ability to choose the kind
of model that you want for your
embeddings and also for uh setting like
what is what is your which directory
what's the path that you want to use
what the document paths is well all
those things all I've done here is I put
that uh into a proper you know dot file
dopy script that that allows you to
train your uh Vector database
separately in
the in the config.py this is where I've
set set up all the all the models the
eming model that I've used GPD model
that I've used the the directories where
I have the data where I which key I have
with open AI key all those things here
um you can you can definitely take them
as inputs but I've set them up here in
the configuration
file um I've already looked up create.
piy and I have LM dopy here as well so
this is where so this is where I set up
once again uh the llm the embeddings the
vector
DB uh fetching from from my
configuration the pa the opening I Keys
the kind of model that I've used
and um and also I've set up U the vector
DB with the default search strategy and
then with uh the Q um conversational uh
retriever chain so that you know we we
you know we Sue this and sew this as a
as the as as a conversation chain and um
and then we've got this
uh uh We've added memory as well to this
and then this is where where this this
is the this is a function that is being
called from streamlet interface every
every time you enter a prompt if there's
a prompt in it it hits here and you know
sends the question along with the
context and then it gets a response so
that that's the response that is being
accessed from the streamlit front end
the streamlit front end is also a very
small bit of code that's the web
app.py so it's very it's it's a very
clean code very has says like if there's
no message currently if there is no
nothing in the messages that means
that's just the start of the just start
of the chart and says okay the starting
message is howy and then over there um
if if if it finds messages then then it
starts app pending to it if you find if
there's a prompt in there then uh it it
writes The Prompt shows the prompt up in
there after you press enter and then it
basically sends the prompt back into the
the previous function that I showed in
the in the previous class and um from
there it gets the response and once it
gets say response it again shows it in
the front end chart
here
okay so that's how it
works
and this is how you can interact with
it
I hope it
works
okay
so it missed some of the context in
there so this these are things that
sometimes happens and this is very
practical uh because it's already missed
some context in here uh while I um while
I created this now uh that sometimes
what happens is you
the keywords don't
match so where does the web app.py run
you have
to so let me stop sharing and share my
screen again
um so I have I have used py charm to so
I use it
from can you see my screen so I just go
from command line
and in your python environment I go
streamlit run uh web app.py if you're if
you're uh if your python setup from your
command line you can go uh you can
literally go
like
you can type this in in your command
line
python minus
M uh stream lit run web app if you
cannot access your uh python environment
from your command line you can go python
minus mream let run web
app.py uh that's how you have to run it
you have to install streamlet before
that
so what happens it it runs out out of
the context window because the context
is so large and sometimes so because
even even with the temperature set to
zero it it does uh so this this response
has changed three or four times now um
you have to and you what you have what
you can do is you can enhance your
searching uh search um retrieval
strategies into some other so I I think
mm mm could work very well for
this and um and then once you've once
you've set the context then you can
ask
so and so on and so forth uh but like I
say so the limitations here as you've
seen already if if your if your context
window is too large in in that case
it'll lose the context because it
doesn't know what it and what this would
will refer to right so that was that's
something uh to take away from here from
this talk and uh and sometimes so from
practical presentations what I've seen
is that sometimes you have to be very
accurate on what exactly keywords that
you're asking about to the chatboard so
it is intelligent but it's not like
absolutely humanik human intelligent so
when you uh for example I'll give you
very very one of the basic examples that
I've seen is um you know child care
benefits maternity benefits um you have
to be very specific it doesn't give you
uh the entire result from there you have
to be very specific about the word that
has been written in the document so that
it retrieves exact information it gets
confused sometimes about very similar
syn syn um confused between synonyms and
it can also miss the complete context if
you give a synonym some time because it
just doesn't know that it's refer that
that it's supposed to refer to something
that that H that's represented in in in
another word so you have to be very
careful when you deal with this it all
depends on on you know depends on how
you have designed it to respond to your
prompts because you know I there are
other other ways of implementing these
you can use prompt template with context
as well to retain your memory as well
the different other strategies to to use
to improve
this um but yeah and uh we can go back
to our presentation for the last bit
unless there are any questions let me
just go and
check
have you been able to run web
app.py uh you have to give it some time
I
think
[Music]
um I don't know why you use why you
using orc
um have you have you are you using your
person is this your personal one or cuz
I haven't seen or in mine I think it
comes when you set up an organization I
have my personal PQ it starts with
something like SK or something but
anyway I think we can we can take this
offline um says limit three use three
requested one I'm not very updated with
the uh with how they have restricted uh
the usages now at this point of time
because I have I haven't been using
uh my personal key for some time I used
it today so it works fine but I also
have I'm using a paid plan um which
works fine the cost is not too high uh
because I was learning I was like okay I
can I can invest that kind a little bit
uh it's not it's not doesn't go beyond
like I think five $5 doesn't go beyond
that at all only when I'm you know
testing heavily um only then it goes
like that that high okay so I will go
into the last bit today uh the
advantages and the disadvantages to
summarize um the to access the vast
information for context and uh knowledge
you know llms are fantastic because you
are basically
utilizing basically utilizing the whole
pool of information that is available on
the internet and it can generate coh and
human humanik responses as opposed to
rule-based engines that would from where
you have to only select like a few
options and then if they're if if if you
have anything else to ask it probably
wouldn't you know be able to answer any
questions but with the with uh with the
llms and you know the current
state-ofthe-art models you can you can
you know build a more um more friendly
and welcoming and more accurate
environment for your customers to
interact with um in on chat Bots it can
also offer creativity like um generating
stories and you know open-ended question
answering uh any kind of template
generation like we've already seen
before and then the most important part
here is performance and speed especially
for open AI the performance and speed
accuracy has been really massive um
speed is it does it does the job in in a
few seconds whereas I've I've tested
with llama before it takes a bit of a
time to to generate responses that the
performance is is uh you know not at par
with open AI as far as I have
seen um so but then in general with open
a and it's been used for you know lot
many purposes um they for the
performance and speed has been
phenomenal uh for uh for basic use cases
and then for in terms of the
disadvantages yes hallucinations is
something that we all need to be careful
about from open ey U you know it's it is
really it's very risky in the industry
to you know produce hallucinations and
present it you know to the users because
that can cost you a lot um it relies on
pre-existing data and could therefore
have outdated information right um and
we've already see that um and then
biased or inacurate data as well in
terms of the disadv disadvantages
although I had personally you know tried
checking uh biasness in the model where
you know I as for like uh can you tell
me five or six um leaders in AI domain
or leaders in you know leaders in the
world like uh political leaders as well
you know um astronauts and what it very
well does is it it lists a good mix of
gender um when when it presents the
names but that also shows that you know
they have invested good bit of time in
you know removing bu
like I said that it's really really not
very we we cannot we it's it's too huge
data to pick out every single biasness
every single um problematic um harmful
content you know unsafe content from the
from the database so therefore llms are
prone to having these bied or inacurate
information that you're not supposed to
show which does not follow proper
protocols
or you know hate content hate speech all
those kind of things and then um and
then resource intensive uh fine tuning
so when you when when when if you want
to fine tune fine tuning is not the best
to use in terms of using llms few short
learning works the best that's what you
know have been established U so far um
few short learning with some examples
and giv giving clear instructions get
gets everything done so it fine-tuning
it would only be necessary for very
specific use cases that cannot be
handled using uh few short prompting few
short learning um or or in that case
Zero short learning because uh you see
uh things like sentiment analysis or
sentiment classification is now just uh
just like well zero short learning it's
you don't even have to give uh examples
you have to give examples only when you
need it in a certain format so if I just
say uh can you give me the sentiment for
um for a particular sentence it'll it'll
tell you uh this sentiment is negative
okay it could say negative it could also
say zero it it could also say minus one
but you need to set a standard and say
hey if it's negative give me zero if it
positive gives give me one or it or if
it is negative give me n if it's
positive give me P you have to set in
that case you have to give examples and
set the context and tell them tell the
llm to you know give you the give you
the response in that particular format
that's that's um and that's very
important so that's the that's the disad
disadvantage of um of the of the llms uh
but all in all we have a future that we
can cannot deny that LM llms and the
open AI not just open AI um these um
hugging face and uh and llama B Bard
they're all they're all going into the
future it's I think 2024 is even more
exciting to see where we go where we
land up with this highly highly
efficient uh language models uh that has
the ability to now think and answer like
humans where do we go next from here
it's an interesting conversation for
next year I have also added some
references that I used to create this
the slides and also the notebooks for
today there are great some of the great
um one of the my favorite ones for Lang
chain to learn Lang chain I think is
this one um the third one and um I've
been using that and also L chain dogs
the Lang chain uh the documentation is
really good so um if you want to explore
more or learn more about you know uh
about about Lang chain
what are other strategies that you can
use because this is this is just a sneak
peek of like you doing it at a very high
level what other things you could do
it's you know you free feel free to
explore that um what we've just done is
we've actually used rag strategy
retrieval augmented generation where we
have you know we we've searched and you
know given the retrieval strategy and
the retrieval uh context along with our
prompt so we've actually done rag
strategy just right now um and so if you
want to read a little bit more on that
that's there from IBM's research um yeah
and any that's it hope you've learned
something from this and uh let me know
if you have more questions